s
sont pour l'instant les seuls
à protester contre la défaite
de leur candidat, le président
Jair Bsosonaro. Dès le résultat
de l'élection, ils ont bloqué
les routes de la plupart des
États du pays et en particulier
l'axe crucl l Rio de Janeiro-
Sao Paulo, s'en prenant à
l'occasion aux automobilistes
partisans du vainqueur, Lula.
Leur syndicat, la police,
négocient une solution.
Mais la nuit dernière, au
palais présidentiel d'Alvorada à
Brasilia, aucune réaction, aucuo
après le résultat.
Et au matin, il n'est pas allé
rencontrer ses partisans, son
petit cerc, , comme il le fait
tous les jours.
À Barra de Tijuca, l'entrée
des Résidences de Barra où
demeure Jair Bolsonaro à Rio est
déserte. Plus de journalistes,
plus de partisans.
Papito, qui hier encore faisait
des affaires avec le nom de Jair
Bolsonaro ne s'est pas présenté
au travail. Ses objets vont
passer au rayon des souvenirs
et il va devoir changer
de vocation.
Seul vestige de la propagande :
ce Lula gonflable en costume
de repris de justice, quelques
autocollants politiques que le
service de la voirie a négligé
dans son grand nettoyage.
L'histoire change de direction.
Hier soir lesarartisans du
président sortant se lamentaient
de la défaite en priant pour
un miracle
(acclamations)
Contraste avec ces partisans
de Lula du quartier branch
de Flamengo à Rio...
- Lula! Lula! Lula!
- ...qui se réjouissaient sans
retenue du départ d'un président
détesté.
(acclamations)
Ils sont jeunes, sympathiques
et joyeux derrirere un président
de 77 ans, fondateur du vieux
Parti des travailleurs.
Un revenant LuLuiz Inacio Lula
Da Silva; deux présidences,
un cancer, le scandale
de corruptption du siècle,
18 mois de prison et qui célèbre
une journée historique...
...où la majorité des Brésiliens
ont dit qu'ils voulaient plus
et non pas moinse e démocratie.
Mais il aura fort à faire.
L'extrême-droite bolsonariste,
la ditite conservatrice et
religieuse, évangélique, seront
puissants au Congrès et chez
les gouverneurs des États.
RICARDO HENRIQUES,
analyste politique
- C'est le moment le plus
difficile, parce que la
radicalisation, du point de vue
des visions, des possibilités de
la société, a pour la première
fois mis en place une vision
extrême, qui a l'intention
de détruire les fondements
de la démocratie.
- Ricardo Henriques a déjà
travaillé pour lui, il croit que
Lula est capable d'y arriver.
- C'est très difficile.
Mais Lula a une vertu qui est
la capacité d'entendre ce que
les gens ont besoin.
Et je crois, c'est pas sûr qu'il
va arriver à faire ça, mais je
crois qu'il a tous les éléments
capable de produire une grande
concertation nationale.
- La transition jusqu'au 1er
janvier sera difficile, Lula en
a donné la charge à son vieil
adversaire de centre droit
Geraldo Alkmin, qui sera son
vice-président, une figure
rassurante.
On dit à Brasilia que Jair
Bolsonaro s'est réuni avec ses
ministres et ses conseillers
et qu'ils lui recommandent de
ne pas contester, de reconnaître
la victoire de Lula. Va-t-il
le faire et comment?
Il doit prendre la parole,
au plus tard demai